plus de 135 vaccin contre la coved 19
sont en cours de développement une
véritable course contre la montre voici
ce soir un tour d'horizon sur les
recherches en cours avec inès bauer
fondatrice et associée directrice des
marques m qui est un fonds de capital de
risque en biotechnologie de montréal qui
participent au prix de démarrage de
projets universitaires bonsoir madame
hausse bauer 11 mois alors qu'est ce
qu'on sait en ce moment des entreprises
qui tentent de trouver un vaccin contre
la copie 19 mai en si premièrement que
quand on regarde et 72% des projets qui
sont en développement qui sont
développées par des compagnies
pharmaceutiques ou des compagnies de
biotechnologies donc énormément d'argent
qui étaient investis dans le domaine il
28% par contre qui vient de centres
universitaires ou de 200 tragédie de
recherche économique
donc c'est une bonne collaboration entre
large le public et le privé et donc on
est on est en recherche en développement
quelles sont les étapes pour arriver
véritablement à produire un vaccin alors
avec ça il faut penser au bea pas du
vaccin c'est à dire pour qu'un vaccin
soit efficace il faut qu'on introduise
un corps étranger dans ce que si le
virus à l'individu et son système
immunitaire au pouvoir monter une
réponse immunitaire stable et prolongé
donc en premier il faut voir qu'est-ce
qu'on va être deux comme corps étranger
dans l'individu on peut hein on peut
utiliser le virus lui même auquel on va
enlever les parties qui cause la maladie
on peut aussi utiliser une partie du
virus une protéine dont on pense qu'elle
est assez forte et qu'elle veut pouvoir
créer une réponse immunitaire stable et
prolongé où on peut donner de la
molécule qui permet de l'édifice de
bâtir la protéine protéine virale qui
éleva jeu c'était une réponse
immunitaire donc en premier il faut
tester les différentes stratégies qu'on
a dont l'appétit la recherche
préclinique on va tester chez les
animaux voir s'il ya une réponse dans un
modèle animal est ce que c'est cette
horreur
enfin nancy c'est avant la phase 2 les
toutes les phases préclinique pourquoi
alors les les fans chili donc après
avoir testé et validé chez les animaux
on va tester pour la toxicité dans les
plus gros animaux puis on va se
retrouver
éventuellement en phase clinique dont la
phase 1 qui la phase aux artistes
uniquement l'innocuité alors est ce
qu'il ya une toxicité qui posés par les
vaccins ensuite emballé en face de nous
on veut tester les doses l'innocuité a
pu un peu plus grande échelle et puis
finalement la phase iii où l'on va
tester l'efficacité à la meilleure dose
et la dent on parlait de 135 vaccin là
mais la phase 2 dont vous parlez on est
seulement à 8 ans qui sont à la phase 2
à peu près oui alors que sait-on pour
chacune des entreprises qui sont
justement la phase de bon alors on a le
la compagnie qui est vraiment la plus
connue 5 aurélie qui s'appelle moderna
qui utilise une plateforme de
technologie qu'est basé sur la rn king
compagne qui développe des vaccins quand
toutes sortes de virus est possible
qu'ils travaillent en oncologie alors
ruiz ont ils ont la particularité
d'avoir une association avec le groupe
lonza pour la fabrication et puis ils
ont communiqué les résultats de phase 1
par voie de communiqué de presse
ce qui a suscité énormément d'intérêt
aurez vous les marchés publics c'est une
compagnie publique américaine alors le
titre et pagnol groupe
exactement c'est une société qui est
passée de 65 dollars par action à 80
dollars par action au moment de
l'émission de ce communiqué de presse
qui est rapidement redescendu par contre
55 pour éventuellement se stabilise et
marc 65
lorsque les gens ont commencé à réaliser
qui leur manquait peut-être des données
où qu'ils n'avaient pas eu accès à
toutes les données par dans le
communiqué de presse mais c'est quand
même une compagnie qui met kita quitte
avant coureurs dans le maine des sirènes
donc ça devrait s alors 5e iob
bibliothèque father et fonctionne pharma
également alors bio un texte une
compagnie allemande qui travaille sur le
même genre de technologie ka moderna et
elle pris la voie de ce partenariat
alors files ont acquis les droits
mondiaux pour le produit de bioéthique
et donc procurer de l'argent à biotech
et de l' expertise pour le développement
de son rex un iphone en a qui nous a
chinoises dans le même but et là il y en
ad'autres on pourrait pas faire toute la
liste au complet mais par exemple
astrazeneca et l'université d'oxford
et même il ya eu tentative de fusion
avec gilead qui est un autre acteur
important dans le secteur
oui ben dilla buste est passé par un
vaccin c'est un traitement qu'ils ont
testé ça s'appelle le rem de sévir
c'était un médicament qui fonctionnait
conflit mollahs et qu'ils ont testé dans
les codes d'infection sera ce cover les
résultats imparfaits
on n'a pas eu exactement les résultats
qu'on escomptait mais on a vu une
diminution la symbologie qui permettait
de réduire de quatre jours la
récupération des malades
alors ça a été assez comme d'année pour
qu'il puisse avoir le mot location du
produit de dans certaines conditions
très très précise et puis victime en la
rumeur veut que astrazeneca aurait
appelé guinée alors on parle de cigares
balle qui va durer très longtemps son
appel de poison pour essayer voir s'il
est dû pour s unir vu que astra si un
vaccin et d'un contrat coville qui a le
plus de potentiel de gagner en quelque
sorte cette course puis d'arriver avec
un vaccin
c'est extrêmement difficile a dit je
vais vous dire le l'attrition le taux
d'attrition dans les vaccins c'est de 95
94 % se servir que pour 125 qui sont
tendues le rex en développement il y en
a 80 ans ont échoué
alors c'est très difficile de savoir
d'avancé lesquels vont pouvoir réussir
peut-être le premier c'est pas
nécessairement garant du succès éventuel
dans l'excellent temps les études de
phase iii surtout que dans ce que si ton
vaccins contre l'espace copter on
multiplie les risques on utilise des
plateformes de technologie qui n'ont
jamais été testés dans des phases iii
pour toute maladie incluse on utilise et
donc on n'en comprend pas nécessairement
ni le comportement chez l'humain la
production parce qu'il va falloir les
produits rae nord michel ensuite on
connaît pas très bien les répondront
comprend pas encore tout à fait très
bien la réponse immunitaire humaines au
sera au virus lui même alors on est
potes on n'est pas complètement certain
de d'utiliser les meilleures mesures
d'efficacité donc plein de risques - qui
nous permet de croire que les 94%
d'attrition pourvoi dans la dans ledit
de complexion général c'est vraiment un
chiffre qui traient riani oui il faut
pas retenir son souffle le vaccin
pas certain qu'on va convoler
l'atteindre prochainement mais ça dépend
de la définition de prochainement mais
effectivement ça va prendre un certain
temps avant qu'on y arrive c'est très
important de prendre ce temps là parce
que le mec on fonde beaucoup de
décisions santé publique sur
l'utilisation du vaccin
absolument c'est qu'on est pressé dans
notre cerveau bien sûr à propos de cela
i know about merci beaucoup je vous dis
oui